you know the only movie
that i went back recently that we made
and we watched
um and i was surprised at how well it
held up was water
you know for many many years they didn't
really want to see it because i thought
ah the movie didn't work you know it
wasn't it it wasn't what
the script was it was not as good as the
script
you know it had its production problems
and then i went back and saw it again
it's like
oh yeah this movie age is great with
time right
and there's a certain director who i
know you're going to ask me about
and we're going to he's going to come on
board with us and we're going to do
you know the streaming version of that
of that movie the continuation of that
movie
when you say the continuation do you
mean where it exists
in the same universe as that film like
you have to have seen the film 20 years
later
all those people 20 years later we're
not 100
sure on the approach to the show but but
definitely
uh we we are in the uh we're in the
we're in the building
stages right now is that an ip that you
guys
own or is that how does that work we're
producing
larry gordon and myself um you know um
were the producers on that movie
and you know we are um
you know with john we are um you know
all reimagining it for the streaming
version
got it do you guys are you is it going
to like a disney plus
or you still don't know where it's going
i think we know where it's going i don't
know if we're allowed to say
yeah we got it for now it's at universal
television
and uh yeah and and we are putting it
together and but yes we
we think it already has a home yeah
i have so many questions about this i
wish i'd rewatched the film uh
more recently we're going to do it with
dan trachtenberg just so you know
because you do i yeah he also did
he did the pilot of the boys i mean
exactly amazing
great pilots where are you exactly in
the development process
we are in the development process
we're early stages dan's attached you
know we're breaking story now
and we're talking to a few different
writers uh and we should have a writer
locked in i would think over the next
couple of weeks
got it so you don't have like a show
runner or anything yet not yet not yet
we're talk we're talking to folks but
nobody locked in yet